filet mignon is a really wonderful high
quality piece of steak it's a bit
pricier than other cuts so it can be a
little intimidating but whether you're
splurging for a special occasion or just
honing in on your skills here's a few
foolproof ways to make sure you get it
right and get the most out of it
[Music]
30 minutes before you start cooking you
want to take your steak out of the
fridge and let it rest at room
temperature if you grab it straight from
the fridge and throw a cold steak in a
hot pan it'll bring down the pans
temperature and you won't get that great
crust
next you want to pat your steak dry with
a paper towel this will absorb any
excess moisture that could keep the
steak from getting an even crust
so then you want to really generously
season the steak with coarse salt and
pepper
this might seem like an aggressive
amount of seasoning but you really need
that much to get the flavor throughout
the steak and don't forget to cover
every side
next we're going to sear the steak
for searing you should use a stainless
steel or cast iron pan because they're
oven safe and can maintain a high steady
heat which you need to get a really
great crust
heat the pan over high heat for about
five minutes
you can actually feel the heat coming
off the pan when it's ready then we're
going to add a neutral oil with a high
smoke point we use grapeseed oil but you
could also use canola vegetable or even
sunflower oil
once you see the oil start to shimmer
like this and it's starting to smoke
that's when you know you're ready to
start searing
place the fillet in the pan and let it
sit for two to three minutes without
moving it seriously don't move it that's
going to allow it to form this really
great crust also known as that mild
reaction after that crust is formed flip
your steak
if it's sticking to the pan that just
means it's not ready yet and you should
let it keep searing until it itself
releases
if you really want to enhance the flavor
of your steak you can baste it to baste
you want to add a couple tablespoons of
butter along with some herbs and garlic
to the pan
then you tilt the pan so the butter
pulls on one side and continuously spoon
that herby butter over the steak for one
to two minutes this process is a really
quick step to infuse your steak with
even more flavor
trust us you should try it
so we're going to finish our steak off
in the oven because it's the easiest way
to guarantee an even cook place the pan
in a preheated oven at 450 degrees seven
minutes will get you a perfectly done
medium rare fillet which is what we'd
recommend it should be 130 degrees when
you take it out of the oven after
letting it rest the temperature will go
up to 135. if you prefer a different
cook you can adjust the amount of time
in the oven we prefer medium rare
because well your steak is going to stay
really tender and flavorful
then you want to let it rest at room
temperature for about 10 minutes to make
sure it stays tender and juicy if you
slice it right away the juices will run
out which can dry out your steak
when you let it rest the juices will
absorb evenly throughout the steak
keeping it tender the temperature will
continue to rise by about five degrees
while it's resting
with any steak you want to slice it
against the grain filet mignon is
already a really tender cut of steak but
this is just an extra tip to make sure
it's the best it can be
and that's all it takes
filet mignon is a really wonderful cut
of meat but it can be pretty
intimidating because of its price point
but when you want a splurge give it a
try it's not fundamentally harder to
cook than any other cuts of steak the
same principles apply and with these few
tips in mind you're guaranteed to get a
restaurant quality steak at home
i mean you can make it for your spouse
for yourself for yourself i've made it
for myself many times if you're trying
to woo someone it's a good it's a good
woo
it's a good woo steak
[Music]